>> Okay.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Maxim Koretskyi, but I'm also known
as the Wizard because I like to talk and write
about complicated stuff, topics that sometimes
are seen as mysterious, and hence the name
The Wizard.
I'm going to be talking about why Angular
and React, the top web frameworks we have
today, are so fast.
I will present a few JavaScript opened myself
techniques that these frameworks use to make
JavaScript run fast.
Now, I work at AG Grid.
This is where we develop the best data grid
in the world, so, if you need the data grid,
we have a free community version with a lot
of features, so definitely give it a try if
you need data grid.
I'm also the founder of Angular and dev community
where we write and publish articles about
advanced topics of Angular.
So, we will be talking about three things
today: monomorphism, bitfils, and filters.
How many know about monomorphism, watch talks?
Something?
Okay.
I watched a talk by Benedict last year, gave
a talk about monomorphism.
I will give you an overview of what it is.
I will talk about bitfils and how Angular
uses structure known as bloom filters.
Let's start with monomorphism.
I do a lot of reverse engineering.
I sit at the computer with debugger and go
through the sores of the frameworks.
These are the comments that I found inside
Angular and React sources.
So these are the comments by technical leads
of the frameworks, and they talk about hidden
class.
And internal data structures called fibre
and view nodes.
They want to ensure that these internal data
structures share the same hidden class, and
that is to make property access monomorphic.
So a bunch of words when I first encountered
that, I didn't really know what they were
talking about.
We need to clarify today what is hidden class?
What is monomorphic property access?
Why is it important in what are these data
structures, like fibre and view nodes?
Let's start with data structures.
Fibre nodes and view nodes in Angular are
used internally to represent a template, basically.
When you define a component, this is the declaration
of a component in Angular.
Angular uses view nodes, data structures,
that it creates to represent a template.
They define the metadata needed to render
the DOM, and it also specifies which part
of the DOM needs to be up dated.
Something called bindings.
How many of you work with Angular?
The same thing in React.
We also define components, we define a template,
and React uses fibre node.
This is new React fibre 16 architecture.
It uses fibre node to represent the DOM.
How many use React?
About 40 per cent.
Fibre nodes and view nodes are used by these
frameworks to represent a template.
This is something in between the declaration
of a component template and the DOM.
What is common between these data structures
is that they are used a lot when these frameworks
process changes.
Imagine there's a function called update node,
an example of a function, there are a bunch
of functions similar to this one in both frameworks.
This function takes in a data structure, fibre
or view node as the first parameter and then
it reads some property.
What is interesting that these kind of functions
and the property access to easily exceed 10,000
times.
So it reads the data structure 10,000 times,
every single times, changes are being processed.
So it can happen a few times per second.
You can imagine how many times the framework
in JavaScript needs to have access to the
property.
The problem is virtual machines bike V8, it's
a complicated process to figure out where
exactly in memory for the value of the property
is stored.
Hence the virtual machine has optimisation
techniques they use to make the process faster.
First, let me explain to you: when I was trying
to figure out all that stuff, the question
I had is why is it complicated?
Why is it complicated to figure out where
the value is, right?
And the answer is because of something called
shapes or hidden classes.
That is exactly the hidden class that Sebastian
talked in his comment.
So every single JavaScript object that you
write in your everyday code is represented
by the JavaScript object, the object internally,
inside the VM, and this also is the corresponding
shape object.
So shape defines or describes the layout,
which properties the object has, and some
metadata, for example, the offset, where to
find the value in memory.
You might think why do we need this shape,
right?
Why not put all description of the properties
on the object itself?
And the reason is memory save.
So, if we have two objects, on 1,000 objects,
right, there's no need to describe the layout
every single time.
We can describe the layout only once, and
then link this object to the shape that describes
the layout, right?
In this way, we only describe the layout once,
even though we have, I don't know, potentially
millions of objects in memory.
But then, it creates a problem.
What if we want to add an extra property?
Now we want to extend the object A. We want
to introduce the new property "W".
Well, we need to introduce a new shape.
We cannot add the W property to the original
shape.
Because it would mean that the other object,
the object B that points to the same shape
has this property, which is not true.
We need to introduce the new property and
then the new shape.
Then we update links.
The object now, the object points to the new
shape.
The same thing happens if we introduce another
property we create one more shape.
And so, in fact, we end up with something
called Transition Chains.
And it means that, when you try to access
the property, for example, X, the original
property on the A object which points to the
button on the chain.
It needs to go through every single property
upwards and will until it finds the shape
that describes the property.
Okay?
You can imagine that, if you add a lot of
properties in different places and modify
object shape, you will have a transition shape
potentially with hundreds of transitions.
And so, every single time when you access
a property, the virtual machine has to go
through all that process to figure out the
shape that describes the layout and memory
of that and retrieve that information.
So a technique that V8 uses is to make that
process faster.
The idea is simple: the ... is the main word
here.
Every single JavaScript function is represented
internally by the object called closure.
This is where the virtual machine caches some
information about the function, which objects
are used to add parameters to this function,
and the other information.
And feed the vector, and this is the cache.
This is where the virtual machine will cache
some information.
So let me give you an example of how it works.
Suppose we are calling the function Get X
and passing in an object with the X property.
The virtual machine figures out the shape
for this object, right, and then what it can
do is that it can cache the shape of the object,
and then the property, right, because we are
getting access to the X property, and it can
couch the offset, right?
So the next time when we execute this function
and pass in an object that has the same shape,
the virtual machine can only compare the shapes,
and, if they match, there's no longer need
to figure out the shape.
You can just take the cache value from the
offset and use it to resolve the value in
the memory.
And what it also does is it defines the state
of the function, and the state there can be
three types of states: monomorphic state,
monomorphic property access, and polymorphic.
In this case, it's monomorphism because it
- it's monomorphic because it has been called
with one type of shape.
Polymorphic is when a function has seen four
types of shapes up to four times, and megamorphic
is when you've been passing objects of different
shapes, more than four types of shapes.
It's important that you pass objects of the
state to one function so the state remains
monomorphic.
I read the comment that monomorphic property
access can be up to 100 times faster than
megamorphic.
If you take into account this 10,000 times
of access during each change detection cycle
that can happen several hundred times a second,
you can imagine the kind of impact monomorphic
property access can have on the speed.
So frameworks use this to create - actually,
what they do is they want to enforce this
function that takes these nodes, it uses the
same shape, same hidden class for fibre and
view nodes, and that makes property access
monomorphic.
You can have HTML elements, child opponents,
and if you follow object-orientated programming
principles, you would create different classes
for different elements.
These frameworks actually merge everything
into one data structure, one class, with all
set of fields and they use one tag filled
to distinguish between types of node.
This is the code from the React framework.
This is a function that is executed for every
single DOM element, so potentially thousands
of times during each cycle, and you can see
here that they try to distinguish by tag,
and then run the corresponding logic.
Okay, so that is monomorphism.
Now, let's talk about bitfils.
This is the other things that both frameworks
happily used.
Bitfils is a low-level concept.
Those who have programmed with C++, for example,
know this data structure, and bitfils is just
basically an array of bits - zeros and ones.
You can define a bitfil today in JavaScript,
type OB prefix in console and you'll get the
binary fill.
Now React uses bitfils to en code side effects.
Side effects in React are basically just operations
that the framework needs to do on DOM elements,
maybe place an element in the DOM, update
tags, remove element, and, instead of having
an array of strings, for example, that define
operations, they just assign places, and say
that, "Okay, the third bit is the update operation."
So, if the bit is one, I know that I need
to update task.
If the bit is zero, it means that there is
nothing to do here.
And I found that when I was debugging React,
I'm sitting with a debugger, and I'm following
the spun element, and I've just updated the
tag on the spun element, so I'm trying to
figure out what changes it will have.
So the effect tag is this effects filled,
and it's a bitfil, so right after the render
face when it has process changes, the number,
the value, is four, and, because it's a bitfil,
it's binary, so I converted it into like - here,
it is actually the decimal, but I know it's
binary, so I converted it to binary and I
got 100.
If you explore the fill, you can see it's
a third bit, and that's exactly what I expected.
React encoded the update operation, so later
- for example, here, when the function update
hosts the facts, it's executed, so, React
will check every single bit and see what kind
of operations it needs to perform.
For example, update will up date the tags.
Now, you might be looking at that and think
to yourself, "Well, why bother?"
This is okay, but it's still too low level,
but there are a number of benefits, and advantages
that bitfils have over other types of data
structures.
For example, with bitfils, there is no need
to allocate memory for JavaScript objects
and shapes, so the virtual machine can save
a lot of space, and because there is no shapes
and JavaScript objects, there are no references,
it means that the garbage collection is a
lot simpler.
You know, you figure out the dependency graph
and know which objects are safe to remove.
With the bitfils, it's one instruction to
the processor to clear the contingent memory,
and that's it.
With the bitfil, it's a smaller contiguous
memory usage and allows for fast access for
a single bit.
It's one twice operator, and that's it.
So that is bitfils.
They're used by both Angular and React.
The last date structure is bloom filters.
It's an interesting data structure.
This data structure is designed to answer
one simple question: is it element in the
set or not?
Well, you can use an array, of course, and
just go over each element, make a comparison
and figure out whether there is an element
in the set or not.
It's quite long.
You can imagine you have one million objects,
you need to go through every single one, and
it's pretty long.
Well, bloom filters allows you to do that
with just one operation.
I show you how to do that.
What is good about bloom filters is you can
get two types of answers - yes or no - and,
when you get the answer no, it means the element
is definitely not in the set.
But when you get the answer yes, it's not
actually yes, it's maybe.
The probability varies.
Because of that, this data structure is called
probabilistic, right?
There is probability here.
You might be looking at that and thinking
to yourself, "Who needs a data structure that
doesn't give you correct answer s?"
This data structure is used most often when
you expect the answer no most of the time.
And this is exactly the case that I will present
to you now.
But first, I will show you how this data structure
works, so each element in the set is encoded
in a bitfil - one bitfils, or a few bitfils
- you will have a hashing function that will
take a value and produce some number.
For example, for John, if we run the function
and we get the number 2, for example, we use
the first letter and the code, for the letter,
we will just use a binary or operator to set
the second bit.
And later, we will use the same function to
get the number for John, but now we will use
the B twice or operator to check if the John
is here.
You can imagine if the bit is not set, if
it is zero, it means that John is not here.
Now, where the problem is why, yes, it's not
guaranteed.
The problem is collisions.
If we use the same hashing function and we
use, for example, the only first letter to
figure out the number, we're passing John
and Jane, they have the same first letter.
Here we have a collision, right?
We end up with the John being in the set and
Jane not being in the set, but the hash function
would produce the same value and we get a
wrong result.
So where does Angular use this?
It uses in a dependency injection system.
So the cornerstone of the dependency injection
system is an injector.
It's a service, a container, where you can
con figure the dependencies between services,
and then the injectors responsible for instantiating
them.
Whereas most systems have only single injector
called Global Injector, Angular has a hierarchical
dependency injection, so, for the hierarchy
of components, it creates an injector.
For each component, you get an extra injector,
so you end up with a hierarchy of injectors,
and let's say the widget manager is provided
in the top-most injector, or the bottom-most
one requires on the widget.
Angular would have to go through every single
injector to figure out where exactly is this
service, and only when it reaches the bottom-most
injector it will be able to resolve the component.
You can imagine it could take quite a while,
for example, if every single injector has
ten dependencies, ten services, it would need
to go through every single one of them and
do comparison which is a long time.
So what Angular does, it introduces a bloom
filter for every single injector, and with
bloom filter, as I showed you, it's one operation
to know whether the service is in the set
or not.
As I told you, the answer is most likely to
go to be no, to so here, no here, and the
last, the top-most, the answer is maybe.
If we get the answer maybe, then we can do
our actual comparison and find the service
if it is there.
So that is bloom filter for you.
Okay, so here's a bunch of protocols that,
if you're interested in that kind of flow-level
details, I've written about reverse engineering,
because I've reverse engineered webpack, other
tools, change detection in Angular, and reconciliation
in React.
So here are the articles for you to check
out.
Also, if you want to learn more about this
kind of topics, you can follow me on Twitter.
I regularly write about some findings that
I pick in these frameworks, and I've written
about my journey, the article you can also
read.
So I hope that the knowledge that I've told
you today that is awakened your curiosity
to learn more about this kind of stuff, and
I want you never to stop learning, and, by
doing so, you will be able to reach new heights
every day.
Because I want you all guys to be extraordinary
engineers.
Thank you for your attention, and good luck.
[Applause].